it can be hard to tell where Bangladesh
ends and India begins that stone marks
the divide put a foot wrong and it could
cost you your life
ma feasel Rahman was found dead early on
January 21st he had a single bullet
wound to his chest his mud-caked feet a
typical of someone who's been working in
a rice paddy two days later at dawn
Kamal Haasan went to tend the paddies
later that day his body was brought back
to his family
wrapped in a shroud he was brutally
killed by the Indian border guards we
want justice for this he was the only
breadwinner now he's dead we're totally
helpless now how are we going to manage
by the end of January in just one month
the Indian border forces had killed 15
Bangladeshis over the past 20 years more
than a thousand people have been killed
according to Human Rights Watch we don't
want any more killings in the border
they can arrest and can punish the
people jail them or find them but
instead they're shooting them dead
sometimes the Indians will take people
just for crossing a few centimeters in
to the other side by mistake and to
detain them for years we want some fair
justice and a peaceful border this is
our request to the government this is
India's border fence but as is the
practice internationally it's set back
from the actual boundary line it's in
the Indian Territory between the fence
and the markers that the shootings
happen now it's this easy to stray from
Bangladesh into India you can just about
make out India carved in the stone there
now the Indian authorities have
repeatedly promised to bring the number
of border killings down to zero and to
introduce non-lethal weapons but it's
clearly not happening the Indian
government has said it's fighting
illegal cross-border cattle trading al
Jazeera did not receive a response from
the government to our questions about
the killings
none of those killed in January was
found with lethal weapons
buzz Nattie Ronnie's son Sansa was also
shot dead last month he could have been
punished or jailed instead she says
Bangladeshis home minister said this
week he's taking necessary measures at a
diplomatic level to stop the killings
similar comments have been made several
times over the past years but India's
border guards are still opening fire
Burnett Smith al Jazeera on the
Bangladesh India border